the New York Times laments digging
through old tweets Joe Biden collapses
in the polling and New York proves
education is about leveling and not
achievement i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show all righty well a lot
of folks in the media seem to believe
that their industry is in serious
trouble and I think that the reason that
the industry is in serious trouble is
because journalism has lost its
credibility with the American people I
mean all too often you look at the New
York Times and you realize this is an
activist newspaper you look at CNN you
realize this is an activist newspaper
people blame that on President Trump in
the media they blame that on President
Trump all the journalists say oh well
it's Trump shouting fake news at the top
that's the problem guys
a lot of us didn't trust you before and
we don't trust you now specifically now
that the mask is off with regard to
President Trump I mean it is very
obvious that the New York Times and
major newspapers across the country have
been engaging in political activism not
journalism for all these years and
they've really thinly veiled it and this
hasn't just been true for the last few
years this has been true for literally
decades going all the way back to Walter
Cronkite who was a committed leftist
going all the way back to Edward Murrow
who is a committed member of the
political left I'm going all the way
back to the Vietnam War when Cronkite
was going on TV suggesting that the
Vietnam War was lost after the Tet
Offensive which it absolutely was not in
the fact is the media in the United
States have been monolithically left
since the 1960s and it's gotten worse
and more activist and more open and the
American people are on to the game well
that has resulted in a lack of trust now
that does not mean that all of these
institutions are losing money that there
were some institutional shifts that
happened in the mainstream media over
the last ten years that meant that a lot
of the newspapers around the country saw
significant losses that includes places
like the LA Times particularly regional
papers saw significant losses because
the only people who are subscribing were
people who expected a physical copy of
their newspaper on their doorstep the
next morning well if it turns out that
nobody wants that physical copy of the
Pope's newspaper on their doorstep the
next morning and then get all their news
for free online then why exactly would
you subscribe to the Los Angeles Times
Los Angeles Times has been bleeding for
years but the neuro Times has found a
way to make that up that's because there
are national newspaper with a wire
service and because they have
extraordinary brand credibility despite
the fact that the trust levels
the media generally are down and so they
have a lot of subscribers The Wall
Street Journal was the first to jump
into the space they have a lot of
subscribers so in other words big
national newspapers are doing fine local
regional papers those are the ones that
are getting hit the hardest now the
reason that all of this becomes
important is because the media seem to
be at wit's end about what to do about
the fact that they are sort of bleeding
out in terms of both credibility
nationally and in terms of money
regionally and that is the twin
narrative for today because on the one
hand you've got the national newspapers
who are complaining that they are now
being targeted as political activists
and you've got the regional newspapers
complaining that they're being put out
of business because there just isn't the
money to run them the the journalistic
industry is in a severe crisis it's a
crisis that really could only be cured
by a systemic shift in how the news is
funded on the one hand and by a change
in orientation on the other moving away
from activism journalism and toward
objective journalism if you hope to
maintain brand credibility at places
like the New York Times now the reason
this comes up is because yesterday we
saw the most bizarre strange response by
the New York Times to a story that I've
seen in a very long time here's what
happened there's a fella named Arthur
Schwartz Arthur Schwartz his good
friends with Donald Trump jr. he is
close with the Trump administration and
he and some of his minions online some
of his friends online started to go
through all of the old tweets of various
journalists at institutions like the New
York Times at institutions like CNN dig
those up archive them and use them for
the possibility of deploying against
these institutions and the New York
Times is really hot and bothered about
this there's an article by Kenneth Vogel
and Jeremy Peters that came out
yesterday called Trump allies Target
journalists over coverage deemed hostile
to White House and the New York Times is
very upset about this resurfacing old
tweets from journalists that's verboten
you can't do that it's one thing for the
New York Times to go dig up private
information on citizens and then
distribute it widely it's one thing for
the New York Times to go after people
who are sort of fringe characters and
politics and try and destroy their life
with old tweets it's one thing for the
entire media to go after Kevin Hart and
try and knock him off the Oscars and
succeed by quoting tweets from 2009 it's
another thing if somebody digs up a
tweet from a New York Times editors
college days that's very very bad that's
the opinion of the New York Times so in
this article Ken
and Jeremy Peters write a loose network
of conservative operatives allied with
the White House is pursuing what they
say will be an aggressive operation to
discredit news organizations deemed
hostile to President Trump by
publicizing damaging information about
journalists ooh
terrible stuff except for the fact of
course that the New York Times has been
doing this for literally years the New
York Times has been going after the past
of anyone they deemed to be politically
politically incorrect they've been doing
this for decades I'm old enough to
remember when they did this to Joe the
Plumber there's a piece by Larry Roeder
back from October of 2008 in the middle
of the an election remember Joe the
Plumber he's this guy who just lived in
Toledo Ohio and Barack Obama was walking
around his neighborhood and he stopped
Obama during a visit to complain about
taxes and suddenly he was this big story
well the New York Times then went and
dug up everything they could on this guy
and basically ruined his life and made
mince was sort of a temporary celebrity
his lines when he was speaking to Obama
but they turned him into a national
level celebrity and they tried to
discredit him as a human being and ran
an entire story that was all about Joe
the Plumber said real deal on Joe the
Plumber reveals new slant as though the
question that he asked Obama was
illegitimate because Joe the Plumber was
not actually named Joe the Plumber
and the New York Times says as it turns
out Joe the Plumber as he became
nationally known when Senator John
McCain made him a theme at Wednesday's
final presidential debate may work in
the plumbing business but he is not a
licensed plumber actually went and did
this and if you remember this for my
younger listeners this is a thing that
happened in real life 11 years ago the
New York Times went and dug up every
piece of information they could on a
dude who asked Barack Obama a question
they said Thomas Joseph the business
manager of local 50 of the United
Association of plumbers steamfitters and
surface mechanics based in Toledo said
Thursday the mr. Wurzelbacher had never
held the plumbers license which is
required in Toledo and several
surrounding municipalities his full name
is Samuel J Wurzelbacher he owes back
taxes to public records show the premise
of his complaint to mr. Obama about
taxes may also be flawed according to
tax analysts contrary to what mr.
Wurzelbacher asserted neither his
personal taxes nor those of his business
where he works are likely to rise if mr.
Obama's tax plan were to go into effect
saying when they dug up all this
information on Joe the Plumber to talk
about his own
personal tax records because he had the
temerity to ask Barack Obama a question
and that is continue to pace that
process has continued to pace just a
couple of years ago
Jared Yates Sexton a quote writer
academic and journalist whose work has
appeared in The New York Times The New
Republic and elsewhere went and dug up
information about a figure online named
Don bleep hole solo hey really just then
a Twitter troll why because that person
had created had created an animated gif
of president from WrestleMania where
he's tackling a CNN logo as a couple
years ago it was a big thing how could
president from do such a terrible thing
and of course it wasn't very
presidential but the guy who created the
Jews just some dude online and this dude
online it turns out we had to go through
all these tweets to find out that he was
a vicious and racist so that we could
then tie president Trump to a vicious
racism so they dug up all this guy's old
tweets and then they suggested that
because Trump had retweeted the silly
jiff of himself tackling a person with a
CNN logo for a face then this then this
guy's life should basically be ruined
and that it is definitely necessary to
dig up every old thing that the guy ever
said and then the guy come and then and
then this reporter Jared Sexton he
started whining about it in Politico he
said before the hour was up I was
receiving messages from the usual
customers anonymous accounts with Pepe
avatars and BIOS declaring themselves
ethno nationalist and white identitarian
yes I'm sure that there are lots of
jerks out there I know because they have
targeted me it's one of the reasons why
I have full-time security but does that
mean that it is a great idea for the
media to start uncovering every bit of
information about people they disagree
with politically you know as the New
York Times who's jumping on the Kyle
cash room shouldn't be able to go to
Harvard University bandwagon because
some of his old friends had resurfaced
crap that he said in a private chat
two-and-a-half years ago before the
Parkland shooting as the media are all
in on the we can uncover nasty
information about people we don't like
or we can resurface old tweets that are
10 years old in order to ruin people's
careers but when it comes around for the
New York Times then they're very sad
about it then it's completely
inappropriate we'll get to more of this
in just one thing this is why the media
lack institutional credibility guys
we'll get to that in just one second
first you know
I had braces when I was a kid
straightening out my teeth but as you
get older if you're not wearing your
retainers you remember you leave the
orthodontist off he's like wear your
retainer is the rest of your life and
you're like come on I'm not a child
anymore
and so you just don't wear your
retainers and then 20 years in the
future you look down on your bottom
teeth in they're kind of crooked well
this is where candid comes in candid has
it has experienced orthodontists
licensed in your state creating a
treatment plan for you here's how it
works it's really convenient and really
easy they create a 3d preview of how
your teeth will look after your
treatments are done Kenzi actually did
this with me so then they send you this
kit and this kit allows you to take
impressions of your teeth and then send
it back in to candidate and then they
formulate the the sort of clear
retainers that you need the the the
clear real liners that you need so
Candida is creating custom clear
aligners and sending them directly to me
right now I actually did this there's no
hassle of going to an orthodontist
office instead you can do it from home
can it cost sixty five percent less than
braces for every aligner purchased
candidate donates twenty five bucks to
smile train and they bring safe 100%
free cleft lip and palate treatments and
children around the globe so you feel
good about yourself while you help
straighten out your teeth at the same
time get straighter brighter teeth in an
average of just six months learn more at
candid co.com slash appear oh that's
candid co.com slash shapiro and use code
shapiro to get seventy five bucks off
which is a great deal that is candid co
comm slash capiro coach shapiro for
seventy five bucks off my wife wants to
do it as well because I mean why not do
it makes your life easier makes your
teeth straighter and brighter it's
pretty great check them out at candid
code comm slash Shapiro
that's candid Co comm slash if you even
if you had braces in the past it may be
worthwhile to get your teeth realign
today because it's been 20 years candid
co.com slash Shapiro use that coat
repair to get seventy five bucks off
okay so as I say the media have long
gone after people that they find to be
politically unpalatable by resurfacing
old stuff and it's usually at the apex
of their career right it's about that
time when somebody reaches a level of
prominence and then the media jump in
people at the New York Times they're
reporters they resurface quote-unquote
resurface old tweets resurfacing old
tweets
means you just searched somebody's back
catalog you find something either take
it out of context or you pump it out
there and then you suggest that this is
indicative of their current thinking and
try to ruin their career over it or
demands an apology and if they apologize
then you say you're only apology
because you used to think this so you're
still a racist so your career is ruined
this is why nobody should ever cave to
the outraged mob the outraged mob is
garbage now the New York Times could be
on the right side of this right the New
York Times in the mainstream media could
be on the right side of this instead of
bothering to resurface old tweets they
could just go ask people what they think
in the here and now or they could hold
the consistent standard instead their
standard is if they're people we
disagree with we can resurface old
tweets and dig up old material about
them and harm them and if they're people
who work for us it's very bad if you do
this if you do this to Sarah Jean very
bad if you do this to one of our other
editors very bad so as I say the New
York Times is very upset about this they
say this is the latest step in a
long-running effort by mr. Trump and his
allies to undercut the influence of
legitimate news reporting oh that's what
this is that's what this is so you're
telling me that Trump and his allies are
trying to target your journalists but
your journalists are sacrosanct so they
shouldn't be held to the same standard
that you hold everybody else to weird
that seems like a double standard to me
they say for people familiar with the
operation describes how it works
asserting that it has compiled dossiers
of potentially embarrassing social media
posts and other public statements by
hundreds of people work at some of the
country's most prominent news
organizations the group has already
released information about journalists
at CNN The Washington Post in The New
York Times
three outlets that have aggressively
investigated mr. Trump in response to
reporting or commentary that the White
House's allies consider unfair to mr.
Trump and his team or harmful to his
reelection prospects so again this is
very bad because they're members of Team
Trump now releasing information about
journalists if your members have teamed
from verboten very very bad operatives
have closely examined more than a
decade's worth of public posts and
statements by journalists the people
familiar with the operation said only a
fraction of what the network claims to
have uncovered has been made public that
people said with more to be disclosed as
the 2020 election heats up the
researchers said to extends members of
journalists families who are active in
politics as well as liberal activists
and other political opponents of the
President and you know what this is what
you guys get you set the standard now
you live by it
play stupid games win stupid prizes
these were your rules and now the rules
are being applied to you and you're very
upset about it sorry New York Times you
don't get to play it like this that's
not the way that this works you need to
go back and ruin everybody's life
because you don't like them politically
guess what your public figures too
now this is what's hilarious okay so the
New York Times it tries to distinguish
between its own coverage and the
coverage of the that is now being
applied to them they say it is not
possible to independently assess the
claims about the quantity or potential
significance of the material the pro
Trump Network has assembled the material
publicized so far while in some cases
stripped of context or presented in
misleading ways has proved authentic and
much of it has been professionally
harmful to its target
they say the information unearthed by
the operation has been commented on and
spread by officials inside the Trump
administration and re-election campaign
as well as conservative activists and
right-wing news outlets such as
Breitbart news this is apparently very
very bad and then they say the campaign
is consistent with mr. Trump's
long-running effort to deal legitimate
critical reporting and brand the news
media as an enemy of the people
the president has relentlessly sought to
diminish the credibility of news
organizations and cast them as
politically motivated opponents you know
what the thing is Trump didn't have to
do that you did it yourself and you
literally just had a leech transcript in
which Dean Beck a your executive editor
over at the New York Times admitted that
they built their entire newsroom about
the Trump Russian narrative and then
that failed and now they're building it
around the Trump racism narrative so yes
you guys are exactly what you what you
purport not to be here's the best
paragraph in this piece by Jeremy Peters
he says using journalistic techniques to
target journalists and news
organizations as retribution for or as a
warning not to pursue coverage critical
of the president is fundamentally
different from the well-established role
of the news media in scrutinizing people
in positions of power oh oh so just to
get this straight
if you're journalists for the most
powerful newspaper on planet Earth then
you're not in a position of power and so
us asking questions about all of your
old tweets is bad however if you are a
fringe member of the Trump
administration if you're an intern in
the West Wing and they dig up an old
racist tweet of yours and blast it out
on the front page of the New York Times
that's speaking truth to power got it or
alternatively you guys are unbelievably
full of crap and you have decided that
the best way to ruin people is to go
after everything they said 15 20 30
years ago
it's tickets to go around digging up
what MIT Romney
said back in 1960 while he was giving a
kid a haircut and then used that to
destroy his life but if we ask about
tweets that your executive editors were
sending five years ago then that's
extraordinarily bad now the real
solution to all of this is everybody
just goes okay fine people said bad
stuff they either agree with it or
disagree with it they either apologized
for it or don't we all move on with our
lives but that is not the standard that
the media have set up and the New York
Times is very upset about this because
they know what's coming they know that
they can't live by their own standard
and good for Arthur Schwartz good for
the people on the right who are doing
this not because I approve of this sort
of activity generally but because if the
left if the members of the news media
are going to play this game then the
rules should be applied to them - there
must be mutually assured destruction
here if all of politics is going to be
an exercise in digging up tweets out of
context from 2009 and then using it
against your political opponents then
you guys ought to live by that standard
- and then we can all decide together is
this a standard that we think is capable
of being upheld or perhaps should it be
a little bit more forgiving should we be
a little bit more understanding of human
nature should it be that people say dumb
stuff sometimes and that is not
indicative of their deeper character all
the time should it be that maybe people
progress over the course of their lives
so the standard of the media have setup
here is that if you ever tweeted
anything bad and now you are a
Republican then you must be ruined for
all time however if you're a Democrat
you can tweet like Sarah Jean Lall day
and be totally cool
and tweet overtly racist crap all day
and it's totally cool well that is not a
standard and so now we're gonna hold you
to your own standard and frankly it's
about damn time it's past time in a
second we're gonna get to the New York
Times issuing this bizarre statement I
mean they should like a full-on
statement from pinched Souls burger the
publisher of the New York Times very
upset about all of this we'll get to
that in just one second first you know
it's really difficult to find good
people I mean just just look at my staff
you know every morning about the time
this show is supposed to start we have a
producer his name is Pavel and Pavel
will will start saying how many minutes
it is past the time we were supposed to
launch with the with the all the
authority of the Soviet commissar it's
very disturbing he's good at his job but
if ever Pavel were to announced the time
incorrectly we would have to find a
replacement for Pavel presumably with a
similarly intimidating accent Pavel
polish well if we were to do that we
would want to go to zip recruiter comm
slash daily wear it's why we use zip
recruiter here at the Daily wire offices
zip recruiter sends your job posting to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
they don't stop there as applicants come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective at four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter and
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
this exclusive web address zip
recruiters outcome slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter com slash Dai ly Wira
zip recruiter com slash at daily wire
zip recruiters indeed the smartest way
to hire also my entire staff loves the
zip recruiter ads because you never know
who exactly is gonna get clocked during
the zip recruiter ad so go check them
out right that zip record comm slash
daily wires if recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ok so the New York
Times puts out in an a long statement
from the publisher of the company called
a campaign targeting our staff Oh boohoo
you see this is me I play the violin
right here this is me playing the
world's tiniest violin just for you guys
uh it's so sad people digging up your
old tweets like you know the bastards
who you employ who do this to all sorts
of people I mean I just I Wow I feel so
so terrible for all of you I mean only
you are supposed to be able to ruin
people's lives this way how dare you
only you guys in the media are able to
go through and make justine sacco into a
national celebrity for tweeting a dumb
joke about flying to Africa and then
ruin her life only you guys should be
able to do that you should never be
subjected to those rules ever ever
pinched Souls Berger writes this this
silly this silly statement he says dear
colleagues we published an article today
revealing a coordinated campaign by
president Trump's allies to attack
hundreds of journalists in retaliation
for coverage of the administration see
because it's in retaliation that means
it's bad well have we ever exist like
this does not hold 90% of the members of
the media are Democrats I'm pretty sure
they have some political motivations in
their coverage in fact I know they do
because they openly admit it when
they're asked about it on undercover
tape or when transcripts leaked it is
very obvious how you guys are covering
the news so you guys don't get to
question the motivations of people who
are uncovering material about your
reporters when you guys have your own
motivations for
your journalistic work I remember I
visited the headquarters of ABC News in
New York one time and there was a big
slogan on the wall about quote unquote
doing good and I thought that's really
not your job your job is to report the
news your definition of doing good mayor
and directly counter to my definition of
doing good I mean for God's sake George
Stephanopoulos was in the Clinton
administration as your lead news anchor
so I have a pretty good idea that you
have some different priorities than many
of us on the other side of the aisle in
any case the New York Times says this
unprecedented campaign unprecedented
campaign is literally a bunch of trolls
at digging up your old tweets guys
that's why you're locking your accounts
and cleansing them now too late they
already have them this unprecedented
campaign appears designed to harass and
embarrass anyone affiliated with
independent news organizations that have
asked tough questions and brought
uncomfortable truths to light right
which is completely different than what
you guys did to Joe Wurzelbacher
completely different the New York Times
which has distinguished itself with
fearless and fair coverage of the
president fearless and fair cover I love
it when journalists call themselves
fearless in covering President Trump
really how many how many journalists is
he arrested fewer than Barack Obama did
when they talk about fearless yes it
takes great it takes I mean honestly
the journalists at the New York Times
sitting in their air-conditioned offices
typing on computers I mean when I think
fearless I think you don't think about
reporters who are fearless talk about
the New York Times reporters not
reporting on Trump
talk about the New York Times reporters
over in Russia I talk about the ones who
are over in China those are the fearless
New York Times reporters don't give me
the lead reporters at the New York Times
sitting in their plush offices on
Madison Avenue talking about president
from oh you're so brave ooh you're
fearless Wow Wow fearless and fair
nothing says fair like in New York Times
they say the New York Times is one of
the main targets of this assault unable
to challenge the accuracy of our
reporting political operatives have been
scouring social media and other sources
to find any possibly embarrassing
information on anyone associated with
The Times no matter their ranked role or
actual influence on our journalism their
goal is to silence critics and undermine
the public's faith in independent
journalism as opposed to when you guys
target you know like low-level staffers
in the White House comms Department and
then try and destroy their lives so that
you can humiliate the Trump
administration and suggest that they're
employing unemployable
this represents an escalation of the
ongoing campaign against the Free Press
no this is called free speech guys and
these are the rules you set people
digging up your old tweets that is not a
campaign against the Free Press that is
people who are using your crap standard
against your your people end of story
campaign against the Free Press would be
like Barack Obama arresting an AP
reporter and that'd be a campaign
against the Free Press Arthur Schwartz
archiving your tweets not a campaign
against the Free Press not a campaign
against not in any serious way and if it
is I have a very easy solution and your
attempts you just say no matter what old
stuff is uncovered nobody's getting
fired also we are not going to
investigate old tweets and then take
them out of context to harm people
because this is an unlivable standard
then we could all go but go back to our
business right we would stop trying to
ruin the lives of people like Brenda
nice and suggesting that it is deeply
important that Brenda nice contributed
the head of moat former head of mozilla
firefox' that he contributed to a prop 8
effort these are the same reporters who
five minutes ago were suggesting that
Joaquin Castro was doing the Lord's work
in revealing the names of people who had
donated to Donald Trump in his district
and it was it was Joaquin this whole
thing is it reeks it reeks of hypocrisy
and then you wonder why we don't trust
the media this would be why we don't
trust the media guys you hold one
standard for yourselves and a different
standard for everybody else this is
definitional hypocrisy it will get to
more of pinched Souls burgers ridiculous
statement in just a moment first when
the founders crafted the constitution
the first thing they did was to make
sacred the rights of the individual to
share their ideas without limitation by
their government that would be the First
Amendment the second right they
enumerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons with force and that is
the Second Amendment as you know I'm a
big Second Amendment believer that is
particularly true because we have a lot
of safety threats here at the office and
around my house and whatever gun I own I
wanted to be a gun that is going to
operate in circumstances where my life
or the life my family may be in danger
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building rifles is no
different starting in a garage by marine
vet more than two decades ago bravo
company manufacturing BCM for short
builds a professional-grade product
which is built to combat standards bravo
company manufacturing is not a sporting
arms company they design engineer
manufacture life-saving equipment the
people at BCM assume that when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas to learn more about
Bravo company manufacturing head on over
to Bravo Company MFG comm you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that's
Bravo Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the great people who make their
products at youtube.com slash bravo
company USA their videos are terrific
check them out again in Bravo Company
MFG dot-com great folks great products
Bravo Company MFG comm so as they say
we're going through pinched Souls
Burgers statement from the New York
Times very very upset at people on the
interwebs who are targeting their
reporters by digging up old stuff and
again they've been doing this on an
ongoing basis nearly daily hey it was a
front-page New Times story when Media
Matters started digging up old clips
from Tucker Carlson on Bubba the Love
Sponge and this was considered national
news so if you guys are doing this to go
after Tucker Carlson's advertisers well
then I think that it's perfectly fair to
go after you and go after your
advertisers cuz this is all dumb but
this is this is the religion of left it
the religion of leftism suggests that
there is no such thing as sin there are
only sinners sinners are people who
don't believe in the religion of the
left so the difference between a sin in
a sinner from the normal sort of
traditional religious perspective is
that everybody sins and we are all
sinners and therefore you have a lot of
tolerance for sinners but little
tolerance for sin the perspective of the
left is you have a lot of tolerance for
sin because there's no such thing as a
sin but there's no tolerance for sinners
meaning people who disagree with the
left those people have to be exposed
they can never be forgiven there's no
purpose in issuing an apology there's no
purpose in getting better that's the
left standard at play well now it's
gonna be applied back to you and the New
York Times is super upset about a
pinched souls burger says this
represents an escalation of an ongoing
campaign against the Free Press for
years the president has used terms like
fake news and enemy of the people to
demonize journalists and journalism now
I is a commentator I've called out
President Trump when I think he's
applying the label fake news to non fake
news I don't like when he uses the term
enemy of the people to describe the
media but you guys you have to it
that your credibility started to decline
long before President Trump was
president Trump pinched Seoul's burger
says now the political operatives behind
this campaign will argue they're
reporting on news organizations in the
same way that news organizations report
on elected officials and other public
figures they are not they are using
insinuation and exaggeration to
manipulate the facts for a political
game um
do that mirrors over the New York Times
offices like it all they are using
insinuation and exaggeration to
manipulate the facts for political gain
I'm fairly certain that just described
the entire New York Times editorial
board you guys literally just ran a
16:19 project suggesting that America
was born in 1619 with the advent of
slavery not in 1607 with Jamestown not
in 1775 in 1619 and then you ran pieces
there were purportedly journalism about
how American capitalism has its roots in
slave plantations I'm pretty sure that
that is a description of what you do for
a living
using insinuation and exaggeration to
manipulate the facts for political gain
in fact the New York Times editorial
bent is a disgrace to many of its own
reporters many of them are terrific
reporters the New York Times actually
does have a bunch of really good
reporters but the editorial bends of the
New York Times makes their reporting
less valuable not more valuable I mean
it's the New York Times that has had
they ran a full-scale anti-semitic cut
cartoon in their international edition
like four months ago the New York Times
admitted back in the late part of 2018
that they had not reported on hate
crimes in New York City because it
didn't fit a political narrative
insinuating and exaggerating to
manipulate the facts for political gain
is basically your stock and trade guys
souls burger says I want to thank the
journalists at the Times and elsewhere
who braved this type of pressure daily
to bring essential information to the
public
slow clap guys this is the scene in the
movie already the slow clap we get the
backlit pinched souls burger speaking to
his journalist and then they stand
slowly and the slow clap builds into a
wild round of a plot yeah you know you
need to stretch her arm out there like
mister like mrs. incredible in order to
pat yourself on the back there pinch he
says under intense scrutiny and routine
harassment they remain undeterred when
our reporters learned of this campaign
to attack journalists they did what our
colleagues around the globe always do
they went to work and started reporting
well I mean they
of how to do that because if they didn't
then you would fire them because they
presumably would not be doing their jobs
is I also want to be clear no
organization is above scrutiny including
the times well then why are you saying
they're about scrutiny cuz some that's
what you're doing he says we have high
standards on our mistakes and always
strive to do better oh do you oh freakin
really if anyone even those acting in
bad faith brings legitimate problems to
our attention we'll look into them and
respond appropriately see this is where
they want to uphold the double standard
right I mean he can't just say maybe
this has all been a mistake they can't
just say that they can't just say maybe
our our pseudo journalism where we dig
up people's old garbage in Twitter and
then pretend that that is representative
of their worldview and their worldview
today they can't just say that's a bad
idea instead it if you bring it to our
attention maybe we'll consider it maybe
we won't but if it's you will go after
you with hammer and tongs he says it is
imperative that all of us remain
thoughtful about how our words and
actions reflect on the times
particularly during this period of
sustained pressure and scrutiny we all
play a part in upholding our commitment
to give the news impartially without
fear or favor what's the proper response
to a campaign like this even in periods
of pressure and change the New York
Times has the benefit of the long view
rights pinched Souls burger we have
served the public for 168 years now
we've covered 33 presidents we know a
free press is vital for our freedoms in
our society we've been attacked and
threatened before we all know how to do
our jobs under fire sorry you're not
braving the the alien Sedition Act here
you're not braving Woodrow Wilson you're
not braving these shutdowns of the press
under President Lincoln like give me a
break
so our response is the same as always
we'll continue to cover this
administration like any other fairly
aggressively and fearlessly wherever the
facts lead ah and the hero music swells
and well even other folks in the media
left are looking at the New York Times
even guys you're ridiculous Eric wimple
who is certainly not on the right has a
piece over at The Washington Post today
talking about how dumb the New York
Times response to all of this is and he
is basically correct I know words that I
never thought I would say I'll get to
that in just one second first president
Trump made a lot of promises during his
campaign and many of them he's kept he's
appointed conservative justices he moved
the embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
in Israel he has cut regulations his cut
taxes he's done a lot of really good
things and he's running that reelection
campaign
in part on that record there's still one
promise that he made that he's trying to
pursue and that is bringing down the
cost of prescription drugs but many on
the left and the press even some big
government Republicans are making it
hard for that actually to happen and the
result is that amazingly enough some in
the Trump administration in the name of
claiming victory would like to push some
form of price controls from the top down
that is not a good idea price controls
rarely achieve their policy goals they
generally result in lack of innovation
lack of investment in particularly the
area where you have imposed a price
control
well what area do you need innovation
and investment more than in prescription
drugs right that is the area where you
need new cures and new treatments price
controls are not going to be the
solution putting price controls on
America's medicine makers could lead to
less RN T which leads to less medical
innovation there's a reason that half of
all medical innovation on planet earth
happens in the United States that's why
I'm asking you to go to don't cap my
carrot right now and help freedom work
stop the Senate from capping your care
by signing their petition right now
again that is don't cap my CARICOM don't
cap my care com go check them out right
now don't cap my CARICOM and fight back
against price controls okay we're gonna
get some more of this on the press in a
second plus Bernie Sanders has a plans
who saved the press which should make
all of your alarm bells start to go off
if Bernie Sanders has a plan to
interfere with the freedom of the press
that is not saving the press that is
just reinsuring in the kind of press
that he likes we'll get to that in one
second first The Daily wire has now
turned four years old so congratulations
to us and to you as a thank you to our
fans we are giving away one month of our
premium a monthly subscription to anyone
who uses the code birthday for all of
August as we celebrate this milestone
we're giving away a free first month
four new premium monthly subscribers
again just use the code birthday time is
quickly running out so come on over and
join the fun it's pretty great also tune
in to day 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
for a latest episode of the conversation
host Michael moles will be answering
your questions live on air so maker
questions better than his answers surely
will be the episode it's free to watch
on Facebook and YouTube only subscribers
can ask the questions so subscribe to
daily why right now get your questions
answered by Michael moles today at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation also just subscribe
generally to daily wire.com when you do
as we say you get that special deal
because you use that promo code birthday
and you get that free month beyond that
you also get the leftist here's how to
call tumblr if you get the annual
subscription it is
glorious it is magnificent you will
enjoy every moment of it
so go join us help protect us against
the nastiness of left that has a double
standard for sure when it comes to
coverage in the media and when it comes
to the right versus the left we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so Eric when pull over at the Washington
Post the media critic over there even he
who's on the left is ripping into the
New York Times for their response to
this this news that people are going
through old tweets of journalists he
says there are bad actors they are
driven to suppress legitimate inquiry
they're by no means journalists and they
read Twitter very carefully these are
the contours of an alarm run on Sunday
by the New York Times just what would
the damaging information uncovered be
illicitly obtains EMS gossip about
sexual habits HIPAA protected
information nope
apparently it's just old tweets among
the central players in the network notes
The Times is a combative 47 year old
conservative consultants Arthur Schwartz
a man who makes no apologies for his
work as the article notes the network
has surfaced anti-semitic and otherwise
offensive posts from other reporters in
the mainstream media and wimple says
Sol's Berger has all but admitted that
the information supplied by Schwartz and
company can be relevant to the
management of the New York Times is good
there's an incompatibility in the Times
story and the souls burgers memo on one
hand there's an attempt to tire the
motivations of the loose network of
conservative operatives on the other
there's a stubborn admission and they
have brought actionable information to
public attention for decades now
representatives of the mainstream media
have answered conservative critiques by
imploring judges by the work we produce
not by the fact that more than 90% of us
are liberal democratic mainstreamers
cannot have it both ways
cut the idol and unverifiable talk about
motivations
if the tweets presented by the loose
network of conservative operatives are
racist or anti-semitic or otherwise
problematic take action if they're
nonsensical distractions ignore them
right even the Washington Post pointing
out at this point that the New York
Times wants a double standard and so
that is correct that is correct now the
credibility of the media is in the
toilet that is one problem for the media
and the media have basically become
overly partisan at this point that means
that they are trying to buy subscribers
with negative news coverage of President
Trump basically Dean Baquet announced
that in that leaked transcript to slate
he said our people who read our
newspaper are rooting against Trump and
we basically know that that is one
problem for the media the other problem
for the media going forward is that
there have been institutional changes in
how the media operates is particularly
true on the local level so local
newspapers have been shutting down why
because it used to be the only way that
you could get the local sports the only
way you could get the local news
was for the newspaper to be delivered to
your doorstep on a daily basis and you
have to pay for well now there are all
sorts of local sites that are running
the news for free and so you don't have
to pay for anything it's it's killing
local news so there are a bunch of
alternative models that have been
suggested 501 C 3 models right people
giving charity so that journalists can
go out and do their work on the local
level and this seems to me a perfectly
fine model if you have a profit-driven
model that's good we have a
profit-driven model over daily weather
the New York Times says profit driven
model based on subscriptions that's fine
on the local level 501 C 3s are probably
gonna have to crop up and then there is
the and then there's the move by Bernie
Sanders to insert the federal government
into the business of protecting local
news okay this is dangerous stuff a lot
more dangerous than the vicissitudes of
the market if people don't want to buy
your newspaper that's a you problem as
I'm fond of saying okay that is a
problem for you and your newspaper
doesn't mean it's problem with you again
I'm going to find you a problem that is
a problem for you to solve that is not a
problem for governments to solve but
Bernie Sanders thinks the government
should step in and protect particular
types of news I can't imagine how this
is going to go wrong the federal
government stepping in and protecting
certain types of news but not other
types of news certain types of
journalists but not other types of
journalists I definitely trust the
federal government to make those sorts
of judgments Bernie Sanders has a big
piece over at the Columbia Journalism
Review talking about how he wants to
save journalism
he says real journalism is different
from the gossip pundit free and
clickbait that dominates today's news
tell me more about real journalism
Bernard mix anders vacationing shirtless
in the soviet union tell me about real
journalism does real journalism in the
words of Joseph Pulitzer is the
painstaking reporting that will fight
for progress in reform never tolerate
injustice or corruption and always fight
demagogues in other words real
journalism is the kind of stuff that you
like because I have a feeling that
Bernie Sanders defines progress and
reform very differently than I defined
progress and reform that he defines it
injustice of corruption very differently
than I do and demagogues I mean he is a
demagogue so I don't think he means that
people should report more stringently on
his campaign but Bernie Sanders says we
have to we have to fight the advent of
the new market in journalism real
journalism requires significant reason
so we have to crack down on Facebook and
Google which is the way that a huge
number of people get their news also he
wants to ban conglomerations and hedge
funds from buying local newspapers which
by the way is not going to stop these
newspapers from going bankrupt I mean
that local newspapers are going bankrupt
whether or not a hedge fund comes in and
saves the newspaper or not
what are his standards I mean this is
this is such a mockery say so Bernie
Sanders his standards for saving the
media is that he would like to ban
consolidation in the media so you
shouldn't be able to buy more than one
newspaper basically he says that he
wants to put in place policies that will
reform the media industry and better
protect independent journalism at both
the local and national levels yes I
think a socialistic top-down government
control guy should definitely help
reform journalism no danger there at all
he says he's gonna reverse the Trump
administration's attempts to make
corporate media mergers even more likely
in the future so he'll ban proposals to
merge big companies he said he opposes
media consolidation he opposed the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 which has
made enormous strides by the way in
terms of speed of the Internet and the
ability for for broadband networks to to
be built he says in the spirit of
existing federal laws we will start
requiring major media corporations to
disclose whether or not their corporate
transactions and merger proposals will
involve significant journalism layoffs
so now he wants the federal government
to start punishing media corporations
for laying off journalists which by the
way does not add to profit incentive
does it how exactly does it make
businesses more profitable to find them
he says employees have to be given the
opportunity to purchase media outlets
through employee stock ownership plans
they're gonna mandate who the hell's
gonna start a new newspaper under these
conditions who in the world isn't going
to just take their newspaper into
bankruptcy and sell off the assets
immediately if all of this were going to
take place there are answers to the
death of local journalism and as I say
they lie in 5 1 C threes they lie in non
profits I mean there are plenty of
places that do have nonprofit
journalistic centers
that's good that's fine they do not lie
in government regulation from the top
and yet now you have Bernie Sanders
using the death of local journalism as
an excuse for the
government to jump into the business of
regulating journalism can't see how this
is dangerous in any way shape or form
yes I definitely trust the same media
that digs up people's old tweets ruins
their lives and then complains about it
when people do the same for their
journalists and I definitely trust media
that have built up Bernie Sanders a man
who wants to use taxpayer dollars and
the power of the executive branch in
order to quote unquote protect the
journalists that seek to cover him as I
think this will all go beautifully and
meanwhile let's take a look at this
Democratic 2020 race there's a new poll
out that is just devastating for Joe
Biden Joe Biden's entire pitch is that
he is going to win right Joe Biden's
entire pitch for the presidency is not
that he's a good candidate it's that he
is the guy who is leading in the polls
versus Donald Trump and he is going to
win well problem is once that balloon is
punctured the airs out and once that
balloon pops
it ain't a slow leak the balloon is
popped and you're done and for Joe Biden
if he's seen as vulnerable he's toast
he can brag as much as he wants about
the general election but if he never
makes it there it ain't gonna matter
there's a new poll out from Monmouth
today it shows that Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden are in a
statistical tie all three of them
apparently Sanders is at 21 as the 20
Biden is in 19 now I would say this is
an outlier poll except for the fact that
this is actually the second poll that we
have seen in the last two weeks that
suggests that Joe Biden has now receded
all the way back to the field
there's an economist YouGov poll that
shows Biden at 22 Sanders at 19 Warren
at 18 now the polls are really all over
the place it's bizarre there's a
political morning console up hold that
is also out today and that one shows
that Biden is still steady at 33% with
Sanders at 20 and Warren at 15 so where
exactly is the momentum it isn't with
Biden and it certainly isn't helping him
that Biden is a terrible candidate he
just keeps gapping over and over
yesterday for example Bernie Joe Biden
was in New Hampshire and he forgot which
state he was in that tends to happen
when you don't actually visit Denny's
for the early bird dinner and and refill
on the energy before he go out on the
campaign trail I'm back I've been here a
number of times last time was I think
all the way back in 2014 but I've been
here before that I
this place look what's not to like about
Vermont in terms of the beauty of it and
what a neat town but I mean this is sort
of a scenic beautiful town the mayor's
been a good guy and everybody's been
really friendly okay so um you're in the
wrong state also he then went out on the
campaign trail and announced that he is
not going crazy which is a fantastic
campaign slogan by the way Biden 2020
I'm not going nuts
um okay Joe that's yeah all right on
health care at the medical school or not
I guess it wasn't actually on the campus
people from the medical school right I
want to be clear I'm not going nuts I'm
not sure there was a medical school man
he sounds like he is just I mean he does
sound like he's 80 right you know why
cuz he's close to 80 that's why so Joe
Biden is having troubles of his own and
then the media obviously want Elizabeth
Warren to be the nominee why well she
checks all of their boxes she is a she
is a woman which is intersectional at
least mildly so she's not Native
American that would've helped her but
she's not and she is a an ideas person
by which they mean she has a lot of bad
ideas that do not mirror her ideas from
earlier in her career when she was sort
of moderate now she is a wild wild eyed
progressive and she also has the
cadences of an upper class in upper
class elite from Massachusetts which is
where she's been teaching for the last
20 30 years
so she fulfills all of their boxes she
makes them feel smart if you actually
want to do well in a Democratic primary
you have to make the press feel
flattered that they agree with you and
they they feel so smart because
Elizabeth she taught at Harvard Law that
means she's smart I just like Barack
Obama I'm Barack Obama made them feel
super smart well you know I'm saying
intelligent things I mean they're like
yeah he's so smart I love I feel so
smart when he's in the room oh it's
wonderful and then doing the same thing
with Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders
doesn't make them feel smart because
Bernie Sanders can't make anybody feel
smart he's like being hit in the head
with the socialistic 2x4 hey Elizabeth
Warren makes them feel smart cause she's
got plans man she's got plans and
doctrines so the media
bring her with I mean the sort they are
just labeling the gravy of joy upon her
it's it's unbelievable and The
Washington Post ran on the front page of
their website a piece called Elizabethan
Warren knows the power of words I'm not
kidding you this is it our journalistic
firefighters we should certainly trust
them I can't imagine why people don't
trust the media I can't imagine it
Peter Marx is their theater critic okay
in the Washington Post ran this piece
I'm sure that I remember when they did
the same about Marco Rubio no I remember
they did this map no I remember
Trump nope the theater of politics the
posts critic reviews the performances of
the Democratic candidates needless to
say rave reviews from the critics
Peter Marx he says she enters in an
ordinary blouse and slacks not a toga
and yet when senator Elizabeth Warren
takes the stage of a music hall in the
sweltering Sun Belt City it is with a
command of the occasion that might have
Julius Caesar's Mark Antony taking notes
I'm never going to stop vomiting it's
just going to be continuous stream of
vomit it's going to be like that scene
in Team America where the puppet just
vomits that's what this is but it gets
it gets better you ready this is
journalism ink
Peter mark says the vocal modulation the
oratorical rhythm the instinct for a
good story she's got the ingredients for
a magnetic performance and she delivers
when Warren speaks you lean in okay I've
been like I took a sample class with
Elizabeth Warren when I visited Harvard
Law School's would've met Ben back in
like 2004 and she was fine I mean she's
she's somewhat charismatic but this is
wildly overstated have you watched her
speeches lately what made her
interesting in a small crowd is not what
makes her interesting on a big stage on
a big stage all of the charm that she
has in small crowds is lost
she seems mannered she seems
over-the-top she's a slightly souped up
version of Hillary Clinton on the
campaign stump but according to the
Washington Post
she is like she's like Shakespearean
she's like she's Olivier now they
literally put this on the front page of
their website friends Romans countrymen
is not exactly where the talk goes in
her 45 minutes
struts upon the tempeh stage on this
August evening in the marquee theatre
capacity 2500 it is so packed some of
the crowd must remain outside in the 100
degree heat still the sense of drama
Warren radiates replicates the momentum
momentum of an actor at the climactic
points of a play her speech may not
convey the compact lyrical eloquence of
Mark Antony but the sights and sounds of
her presentation deliver the centrifugal
emotional force of a potent soliloquy
just as Antony fashioned and addressed
to provoke a passionate response in
which every wound of Caesar should move
the stones of Rome to rise and mutiny
Warren has a gift for infusing a
call-to-action with raw clarifying
emotionality Antony appeals to the
crowds desire to control its destiny
so does Warren I mean this is what I
thought when I saw her dancing in
Minnesota I mean that that's what I see
right there I think Mark Antony I don't
see awkward Elaine from Seinfeld I don't
see grandma at the bar mitzva I see I
see Mark Antony when she's doing this
folks you should subscribe just so that
you can actually see the tape of this so
you know what I'm talking about it's not
good it ain't good are you seeing Mark
Antony here this is our moments in
American history she exclaims her voice
catching dream big fight hard wow I mean
deep words their dream big fight Wow I
mean it's not like she's running for
third grade secretary or something the
audience response is so high decibel her
signature closing line is all but
drowned out you mean her fans are fans
that's crazy but according to the
Washington Post deployed their theater
critic to write this Warren's tempeh
appearance was the first time in my
travels as a theater critic on the 20/20
campaign trail in which I was moved by a
politician's oratory and I could feel I
wasn't the only one
Warren's team seated about a hundred
twenty people on the venue staged to
cheer her on
and one exuberant young man in the first
row was clapping so ferociously I
thought his hands would bleed that kind
of enthusiasm is difficult to
manufacture no it's not actually it
really is not I remember when people
went crazy for Hillary Clinton I do I
mean we can pretend that didn't happen
but that was the thing that I know is
embarrassing for everyone I remember
when there are lots of people who did
this for Ted Cruz in the Republican
Party
but again they deployed their theater
critic to do this
I trust the media so much guys they say
in this hall it came across as genuine
in part because the speaker seemed to be
seeking that kind of intensity one of
the most seductive attributes of great
actors is that they create the
impression they are giving you more of
themselves and asking you as an audience
to give them more in return a warren
performance is a polished act of
seduction dude take a cold shower
mean goodness gracious that's what I see
again polished act is it polished act of
seduction well I'd hate to see what an
unpolished act of non seduction looks
like my goodness as the candidate makes
plain and even makes fun of herself for
she's got a plan for everything except
maybe what you should have for dinner
but I'm drawn to something more
elemental and just as vital for someone
auditioning for the role of communicator
in chief how does a politician convince
you she understands the way you think
how does she share enough of herself for
you to not only imagine you know her but
also want to side with her with Warren
that seems to be a holistic mission one
in which she skilfully integrates who
she is with how she reveals to you who
she is she knows how to bring you into
her spotlight even when the focus
remains entirely on her at other times
Warren can summon a bit too fiercely her
disapproving inner schoolmarm but unlike
Vice President Joe Biden Kamala Harris
Warren has a fully evolved performance
style in a gritty poetic way her spiel
is akin to that of a folksy troubadour
she's the springsteen of campaign 2020
well there it is again Springsteen take
a look look at that Bruce Springsteen
making the magic happen out there
and by the way Bruce Springsteen wildly
overrated all right I can't do this
anymore because I actually have to I'm
getting dizzy from the need to vomit at
this point welds on Washington Post
journalism Inge getting your journalism
everywhere hot journalism all over the
place well done everyone okay time for a
thing I like and then a thing I hate
things that I like today so we talked
yesterday about the deep and abiding
problem with the Chinese government the
fact that they are a strong geopolitical
foe that they have a long-term vision
and that they are attempting to expand
their reach there's a good book on this
by Bill Gertz it's coming out very
shortly called deceiving the sky inside
Communist China
drive for global supremacy the book is
is well researched alerts is a longtime
reporter for The Washington Times and
this is a particularly the book again
deceiving the sky inside communist
China's drive for global supremacy talks
about the history of it what exactly
they're trying to do everything from
using Huawei to invade privacy building
5g networks check out the book again
deceiving the sky okay time for a quick
thing that I hate should we do one okay
fine so quick thing that I hate so one
of the beautiful things about the left's
perspective on education is it's not
about educating children it's about
leveling at the playing field by
leveling the playing field what they
mean is that no one should actually
perform well how do we know this listen
to this
the New York Times reporting on New
York's education plan desegregation plan
eliminates all gifted programs in New
York you got that so in order to achieve
racial parity in the programs in New
York they once will eliminate the
programs for the smartest kids who are
disproportionately Asian in the city of
New York by the way for years according
to et Liza Shapiro no relation New York
City has essentially maintained two
parallel public school systems a group
of selective schools and programs geared
to students labeled gifted and talented
is mostly filled with white and Asian
children the rest of the system is open
to all students and is predominantly
black and Hispanic now a high-level
panel appointed by Mayor Bill DeBlasio
is recommending that the city do away
with most of these selective programs in
an effort to desegregate the system
which has 1.1 million students and is by
far the largest in the country
de Blasio who has staked his mayoralty
on reducing inequality has the power to
adopt some or all of these proposals
without input from the state legislature
or City Council if he does the decision
would fundamentally reshape a largely
segregated school system and could
reverberate in school districts across
the country so now they're going to shut
down the gifted programs in selective
schools specifically because not enough
in Asia not enough Hispanic and black
kids are getting in Asians are wildly
over-represented at these schools this
obviously is because New York is a
deeply racist place or alternatively it
is because their racial differentials in
test performance that are reflected in
who is getting into what school so the
solution is to get rid of the
possibility of better schools and make
sure that
everybody goes to the worst schools
great job New York City obviously you
care about kids
the proposals may also face opposition
from some middle-class black and
Hispanic families that have called for
more gifted programs in mostly
minorities neighborhoods that would be a
better plan would it not still the plan
could resonates as the New York Times
with black and Hispanic families who
believe that these selective programs
unfairly divert money and attention from
neighborhood schools the plan includes
all elementary school gifted programs
screened middle schools in some high
schools with the exception of Stuyvesant
High School in the city's seven other
elite high schools whose admission is
partially controlled by Albin II the
panel says quote gifted programs in
screen schools have become proxies for
separating students who can and should
have opportunities to learn together
okay this is such absolute crap case
studies do not show that when you put
gifted students in a room with non
gifted students that the non gifted
students benefits all they shows that
the gifted students underperform I'm
aware of no study that shows that gifted
students perform better when they are
placed in a mediocre classroom and that
the and that students who are not gifted
perform better when they are placed in a
class with gifted students in fact
precisely the opposite in my own
personal experience I've been in and out
of when I when I was growing up I was in
public school and then I was in private
school and then I was in public school
again and then I was in private school
we bounced around a lot depending on my
parents financial fortunes at the time
well when I was in my original public
school I had to skip a grade because the
classes couldn't keep up with where I
was I skipped third grade and then I
went to a private school and the private
school couldn't keep up with where I was
on the secular side so my parents put me
in a highly gifted magnet here in in Los
Angeles area and the highly gifted
magnet classes were disproportionately
Asian and they were separate from the
other classes in the school now do I
think that I would have learned better
if I had stayed at the private school
not even the public school the private
school where they didn't have the
capacity to deal with me on an academic
level I probably lost a year in math
because I was in a class where the
teacher literally did not know how to
deal with me the teacher was teaching
algebra
I was already passed algebra and the
teacher literally just handed me a
geometry book and said learn it now he
was I think I was 9 or 10 at the time
needless to say I did not learn geometry
that year
hey do you think that you're doing these
gifted students any favors and so you
think you're doing the non gifted
students any favors by basically pushing
the gifted students down into a crappier
system this is insanity and it
demonstrates full scale that the left
does not give a damn about achievement
the left only cares about equality of
outcome and that means that if they have
to force gifted students into worse
classes that they will do it they're not
about raising other students up there
about pushing the great students down so
that you can assure that parity is
achieved even if that means mediocrity
through parity unbelievable all righty
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Klavan show you know people
are saying that America has never been
so divided and they can say that all
they want but it's completely and
utterly untrue what is true is that
there's never been a time at least not
in my memory when the elite
establishment has been rooting so hard
against the country that has given them
everything they have I'll show you what
I mean in the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin